so I'm going to substitute mission for
purpose your purpose is what you are
here for your purposes what do you wake
up excited to do your purposes what's
the impact that you want to have on the
world what do you want to be known for
what do you want to create your purpose
is the thing that keeps you going when
you want to quit when you want to give
up when you feel like it's not happening
fast enough when your goals aren't
enough to keep you going what is the
thing that keeps you going it's your
purpose to feel like what you are doing
today matters is Meaningful is going to
have an impact and people have asked me
so how do you keep going you're one of
the most consistent people I've ever
seen in my life how do you keep going
how do you keep making videos I feel
like it matters I'm living my purpose I
don't think what I'm doing is that
unique that special I think everybody
can do it it's within reach for
everybody to do it the problem is most
people are just chasing opportunity and
just trying to make a quick buck and
making money is very important it is
very important it's just not number one
number one is your purpose hey it's Nina
Carmichael and we made these videos
because you're probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you need
a push by surrounding yourself with the
best so today let's learn from one of
the best my husband Evan Carmichael and
learn how to find your purpose and
successfully follow through enjoy
if you woke up and felt like today
mattered that it was gonna mean
something to somebody you're gonna show
up in a totally different way you're
going to show up with more energy it's
going to be easier to say yes
I was making videos for years with
getting almost no views zero comments
why because I felt like what I was doing
mattered that if a hundred people saw my
video that's 100 people that saw my
video where if you're just chasing the
end goal if you're just chasing oh I
need to have a million subscribers so I
need to have X in my bank account
you stop you will quit because it gets
too hard
where if you actually felt like I'm
gonna show up today and I'm gonna do
something that matters and it's going to
change at least one person's life there
are some days when you feel like you can
change the world right there are some
days when you feel like I can do
anything I could change the world I'm
going to X right there are Sundays when
you actually feel that and it's amazing
and there are some days where that feels
too big and too scary and your purpose
feels too overwhelming and and it should
be it should be aspirational it should
be beyond your reach it should not be
something that just gets solved in your
lifetime it's something that you want to
swim forever to climb forever to keep
chasing down so there are some days
where it feels too big and on those days
don't stress about it being too big
worry about hey I'm just gonna help one
person for me when I'm stressing out
about making content making videos
speaking on stage whatever else I'm
doing some days like I'm gonna change
the world today and other days is
I hope I can reach a few people with the
video
this is a Tuesday for me I record videos
on Tuesday every Tuesday I make content
into my calendar and it's always the
most
stressful day for me
in my week because I always want to make
the best that I can I want I want
today's video to be the best that I can
with what I've got
because I want to have an impact I want
I want hopefully this video and the way
that I say it and just hope that this is
the one that finally resonates with at
least one person The Hope isn't I need
this video to go get a million views or
I'm a failure the hope is
that for you maybe for you maybe you're
the one today
that the way that I say it
hits you in the right spot that pushes
you towards some kind of action to take
that thing that's been sitting inside
your heart that you've been sitting on
for a long time that you know you want
to do and get the permission get the
courage to actually go off and do the
thing
that's what purpose does for you
purpose demands that you grow into a
better version of yourself because you
won't do it just for yourself
if your goals are just purely selfish if
it's just to have money in your bank
account or buy a certain car or whatever
the goals just for yourself will not
sustain you through the long stretches
of bad times that it takes to go off and
actually build something meaningful the
thing that sustains you is feeling like
this is of Greater
service to other people than just me
Okay so
everybody has a purpose the purpose is
the thing that gets you going the
purpose is the thing that keeps you
motivated the person the purpose is the
thing that makes you want to do
something today how do you find it Well
finding it doesn't have to be a
difficult process I wrote about it in
built to serve I believe humans are
built to serve and finding your purpose
comes from your I call it your why and
your why comes in your pain your purpose
comes from your pain your purpose
it's not something that changes next
year or the year after or the year after
it's not it's not what's my purpose for
this year
that's a decent enough conversation even
figuring that out if you wanted to go
down that path what's my purpose for the
year it's already more self-awareness
than what 99 of the world has but that's
still not your life's purpose your
purpose is the thing that at 120 years
old you're still obsessed about my
purpose isn't to grow my YouTube channel
I don't know if I'll be doing YouTube at
120 years old that's too far away for me
to think about my purpose is to try to
solve the world's biggest problem which
is that people don't believe in
themselves enough and when I'm 120 years
old that will still be there and I will
still be doing whatever the the modern
technology is right if it's YouTube
amazing if it's VR something totally
different I'll be doing that because I
want to solve that problem
that's what I wake up everybody trying
to do why well because the purpose comes
from my pain because what I struggled
the most with
me oh Nina brought some coffee we love
you Nina look at the steam look at the
steam I bought this guy coffee and you
bought the homeless guy coffee he says
his birthday it's his birthday look at
Nina so special
he's spreading her purpose love it my
purpose came from my pain I struggled so
much as an entrepreneur
I felt the lowest
as a human I felt worthless I quit on my
business partner I thought it was never
going to work out I I just felt
incredible pain I felt lonely isolated
worthless
and I did quit on my business partner
and then luckily I came back the next
day and just decided I can't quit on
this yet and I'm still making all of
this content all of my material how many
years later let's see that was that was
when I was 19 20. I'm 41 now so 20 plus
years later still helping still making
content still going and it's going to be
another 80 years of doing this because
there are so many people millions of
people who are 19 year old Evan right
now struggling with the same thing
whatever you struggled with
think about in your life that the
deepest
most traumatic experience where you felt
worthless as a human being the most
painful emotionally moment that you had
to go through
and you barely made it you know you
didn't you didn't Triumph your way
through it you struggled but you made it
and now you're here and you're still not
where you want to be but you're way
further ahead than you used to be right
you right now could go back to you from
10 years ago five years ago seven years
ago and give some great advice
that's your purpose
to know that there are millions of
people right now who are currently the
person you used to be and they may not
make it through
they may not make it through like you
did you had the strength you had the
courage you had the strategies you found
the way and you made it through and they
may not and they need you they need your
voice they need your hope they need your
inspiration they need your message they
need you in a way that they won't listen
to me they won't listen to Tom bilyu or
Tony Robbins they won't listen because
they don't connect to us but they will
connect to you because you are like them
so it doesn't have to take you years to
figure out your purpose you don't have
to go to a retreat you don't have to go
meditate on a mountain you don't have to
hire a fancy business coach you don't
you have to you don't do any of that you
already know it
you go back to the most painful moment
in your life
where you felt worthless as a human
being
and then just deeply connect to that and
feel and know that there are many people
out there right now who are that right
now
and they have no hope and no guidance
and no leadership and no wisdom and they
feel stuck and they then they feel alone
they feel afraid they feel ashamed
they're not reaching out they're not
asking for help and they're going and
they're searching they're searching
they're going to YouTube they're going
to YouTube they're going to YouTube
they're going to YouTube how many times
you have to say that they're going to
Google they're going to Twitter they're
going to Facebook they're they're
searching they're searching for help for
answers
you could be the one that shows up
and if you actually felt that
[Music]
that on some days you could change the
world and on some days
change one person's life if you actually
felt that
you'll show up completely differently
finding your purpose and living it is
the thing that gives you the motivation
the strength the confidence
to show up one more day and keep going
rule number two
leave
five percent of the world wakes up and
drives to a job that they hate I believe
that you have Michael Jordan level
Talent at something that you are a
genius you are the best the best at
something most people either one have no
idea what that thing is or two they have
found it but they don't have the courage
or belief to go chase it down either way
the path is through you need to find the
thing that you are a genius at that you
have Michael Jordan level Talent at and
live it every single day if you want to
live your life instead of regret your
life this is why I do what I do I want
people to believe in themselves more I
look at people and I I see this person
who hates their life and and then
there's so much talent you have so much
talent you want to serve you want to
help others you want to make an impact
you want to make a difference everybody
does it's a human condition and you know
you're capable of more than what you're
doing right now you know it and this is
what I want to help bring out in people
it's why I make the videos that I do and
write the Books and do the my speaking
all of it because I want to pull that
out I want you to suck on whatever
energy that I can give you so that you
then realize maybe I am a genius maybe I
do have great ideas maybe maybe what I
have could actually change the world
maybe I need to stop doing the thing
that I'm doing maybe I'll maybe there is
some hope right that's what I want to
try to inject into people and so I have
an eight-step process that I'll take you
through super quick that if you are are
struggling with belief if you are
struggling thinking that I don't know if
I'm a genius at something this process
will help you it'll help you believe in
your big Ideas it'll help you believe in
your capabilities and I'll help you go
off and actually make an impact let's
dive in number one let's find your
purpose you got to find out what the
thing is that you're here to do right I
have my who I have process figure out
who what your one word is your most
important core value to your purpose
comes from your pain the thing that you
struggle the most with is the thing that
you want to help other people through
whatever you struggle the most with them
the worst moment in your life whatever
you remember that is your purpose for
life will be helping other people who
are currently going through that pain
and then through the how how you got out
of it how you got through it will be a
recipe to teach other people you'll be
able to as you take your steps on the
staircase Up Lift other people up to
join you on that step so step number one
in believing in yourself more is
figuring out what is your purpose step
number two is going from idea to action
you have great ideas you have great
ideas the problem is you judge your
ideas you come up with a great idea in
the shower and then you spend the rest
of the day thinking about it researching
planning it judging it saying I can't do
that or how's that going to work and
then you wake up tomorrow a different
person the faster you go from idea to
action well it will dictate your entire
future it'll change the entire
trajectory of your life the faster you
go from idea to action stop judging your
ideas you get an idea you go for it you
do it the two percent difference stop
planning to get to 100 and just take
action on the first two percent you'll
never figure out the whole plan by
sitting on your couch you won't you
figure it out by doing idea to action
train yourself you get an idea you do
something about it because your ideas
list is never going to get any shorter
it's growing every day you're a genius
you can with great ideas that's not
enough you got to do something about
them and so immediate action you get an
idea Boom the two percent difference
what's one thing that you can do that'll
take you two percent of the way to
making some momentum on this idea the
smallest simplest dumbest stupidest
thing that you can do right now today on
your idea idea to action step three is
model success have people around you who
inspire you who lift you up who show you
that it's possible I love my YouTube
channel for for myself I need it for me
I surround myself with Steve Jobs and
Kanye and Oprah and all these people for
me for myself I want it I want to be
around successful people because what it
does it rubs off on you it rubs off it's
like they're sprinkling little Steve
Jobs pixie dust on you it rubs off it
shows you two things one that it's
possible because all of your Heroes they
started with less than what you
currently have right now you feel like
it's overwhelming and impossible in your
environment and it's just it's never
going to happen
whoever you look up to whoever your
heroes are they had it worse than you
have it right now they struggle through
worse and what you're struggling through
right now and so they could do it you
can too there's no excuse if you're
surrounded by people who just tell you
I'll take it easy take it slow yeah of
course of course you can't do it because
you were born on Acts or because you
come from this community of course yeah
just you're never gonna make it right
screw the president screw the system
right most people that's how they live
but other people they've won they've
done it despite coming from worse
circumstances than you you have no
excuse and so when you surround yourself
with those people who are often winning
who who look like you came from the same
background as you struggle with the same
things as you or worse it's motivating
it gives you hope that it's possible you
need to be around success you need to
model it and and it gives you the hope
and it also gives you strategies
Bill Gates saved my company I've never
met him yet but but what he did give me
hope that what I wanted to do was
possible with my software company and
how he got through was a recipe for me I
modeled how he got through it and that
started to take my company forward so
step three in believing yourself more is
you need to model success step four is
create an environment of Excellence an
environment of Excellence what in your
environment makes you feel excellent it
starts with you how you carry yourself I
love wearing this right like I wear this
not just for the camera I like it like I
feel like Batman putting on my outfit
putting on my superhero cape right when
I wear this how do you want to express
yourself from the clothes you wear from
from your haircuts from the Jeweler you
put on how are you going to express
yourself that is excellent
that reminds you of who you are and what
you're capable of next you go out to
your physical environment so these
people are all behind me for a reason I
walk into this office and without even
having to think about it I've got these
people staring me down reminding me to
be excellent to go chase down my dreams
right what's on your what's on your cell
phone background what's on your computer
background right these are things that
you set up once in your environment and
then it triggers you I call them play
bigger triggers they're there for you
every single day to remind you right if
I'm if I'm feeling low if I feel like I
don't believe in myself enough I got my
parents right here telling me hey Evan
you're extremely Carmichael believe in
yourself more if I'm struggling with my
vision I got Steve Jobs
I got Steve Jobs staring me down right
here right I'm Mike this is my computer
I'm looking here I got this guy eyes on
me right no maybe that's too creepy for
you scary few awesome design for
yourself designed for Your Excellence
what makes you feel bold and want to
come alive and have that as a daily part
of your routine step number five is
scheduled for Success so I just
mentioned routines what is your routine
what are you doing on a daily basis show
me how the actions that you're doing
what's in your calendar will help you
accomplish your goals right your actions
have to map to your Ambitions you say
you want this amazing I love it I'm
pumped now show them in your calendar
where you're going to do it you say you
want to have a million subscribers on
YouTube amazing you say you want to sell
a million books amazing you say you want
to have a million dollar business
amazing show me in your calendar where
are you spending your time
on making videos on writing books on
building your business like it has to be
in your calendar most people they don't
have it in your calendar and if you
don't have in your calendar it's never
going to get done and not just business
life success you want to be a successful
husband father mother daughter wife
anything where's that time put in your
calendar right show me your calendar
your calendar is your habits and your
habits will dictate your success and so
what you do on a weekly basis in your
calendar and also how you start your day
every day most people wake up like an
accident most people wake up they hit
the snooze button which already telling
yourself that you you're the kind of
person who doesn't follow through on
your goals and you start responding to
other people's emergencies no start your
day with intention you could have had
the greatest day of all time yesterday
and you wake up today and it's you're
starting over so what makes you come
alive and then put that into your
morning routine with intention every day
so you stop waking up like an accident
you do that you're gonna believe in
yourself more step number six to believe
in yourself more is manufacturing
self-confidence manufacture
self-confidence you do difficult things
you need to teach yourself that you do
difficult things that when something is
hard you want to do it you love hard
things that when your heart's beating
and you're scared you're nervous that's
a sign you have to go do that thing
self-confidence self-love self-respect
comes from following through on the
things you say you're going to do
but it doesn't count until it's
difficult waking up at X in the morning
right you want to wake up at six in the
morning great when it's easy it doesn't
count
you don't feel good about yourself you
don't feel bad it's just it's easy it's
when it's hard it's when it's hard right
if you if you ran a race against
three-year-olds right and you won you
might post about it say yeah I won this
race but inside you know it's a fake you
know it's a fake win it doesn't count
but if you get up and run against Usain
Bolt he's gonna destroy you
but you can feel good that you tried
right are you proud of your effort you
want to manufacture self-confidence you
want more belief are you proud of
yourself today and it's not something
that that anybody else can give you
should I be proud of myself I don't know
did I do enough reps I don't know did I
did I write enough words for my book I
don't know are you proud of yourself
I can tell you when I broke my neck on
my tour and I was sitting at the front
for three and a half hours in massive
pain delivering my presentation I was
proud of myself
even though the quality went down right
I was better when I was being able to
walk around and not have so much pain I
felt like my presentation delivery was
better
but I was more proud of myself for doing
it when it was hard that's how you
manufacture self-confidence that's how
you manufacture self-belief it's doing
it when it's hard it does not count
until it's hard and that you do
difficult things step number seven to
believe in yourself more is beating
negative judgment
if you're doing anything that's
different anything that's outside the
norm guess what there's a lot of people
who love the norm there's a lot of
people who will say
stop doing this they want to protect the
status quo because if you go off and win
it makes them look bad it makes them
feel bad about themself
right you you winning makes them feel
bad about themselves and so you're going
to have a lot of people who all they
focus on is tearing other people down
you may even have your parents who who
are giving you advice out of love but
your parents are pilgrims you are
growing up in a different era than they
did
if you're if you're 20 years old right
now
your parents at 20 years old the world
is different
the amount of things that a 20 year old
can do right now to build a business to
have success to make a meaningful impact
on the world is crazy compared to what
was available when your parents are 20
years old they don't understand the
world that you live in and so their
advice is out of love
but they just don't understand what's
possible and so you get advice that's
out of love that's still negative you'll
see it as negative and you'll also get
hey you'll get people who watch your
videos read your book and say you suck
that's the worst thing I've ever seen in
my life
but what's the alternative
to never ruffle any feathers to never do
anything bold or big or great to to live
your entire life in fear of being
rejected in fear people laughing at you
and so you play small your whole life
and then you're 95 you look back as I
never did anything great I knew it was
capable I never did it you need to learn
to attack judgment you attack it if
you're afraid of even the possibility of
judgment then you do it that's why I
painted my nails a while back because I
was afraid of people judging me for
having my nails painted so then I had to
do it have to do it just to beat it just
to eat the Judgment you need to train
yourself because if you want to go off
and do some some amazing big thing but
you can't do something as simple as
paint your nails you've lost you're so
worried about other people's opinions
that you'll play small forever
and so the next time you feel yourself
worried about somebody else's opinion
then you have to go off and do that
thing now within your code of ethics
right don't go don't go beat somebody up
don't go you know mock somebody don't
don't do something against your values
but most of the things that you want to
do
you want to do it's for you it's not
against somebody else you want to do it
for you and you're afraid of what the
reaction is going to be that's the fear
that you need to quash and as soon as
you catch it you need to say I'm gonna
do it I'm gonna I'm gonna beat that
negative judgment I'm gonna feel that
fear and I'm gonna do it anyway and then
step number eight to getting more belief
is to make an impact we want to make an
impact making money is important it has
to be money has to be in your top five
it's just not number one one is not
number one it's not number 100 on your
let's see there's got to be in your top
five but something comes ahead of it and
that's the impact that you want to have
what is the impact how are you going to
do it and then start feeling it start
seeing it start start appreciating it
you know for me I'm just here in my
office talking to the camera
it's me in the camera alone in a room
but it's going out and being broadcast
and you're watching it right now and I
appreciate that and I and I remind
myself of the work that I do every day
matters is touching people and maybe
that's just one person maybe maybe you
help one person today and you feel the
impact of that or maybe it's a hundred
or a thousand or a hundred thousand or
however many right your impact will
continue to grow with time especially
entrepreneurs we want to have a big
impact not just one person at a time but
remembering that that you're here to do
something good and that your work
matters if you woke up every day and
felt like the work that you do matters
to somebody is having an impact on
somebody is serving other people because
humans are built to serve and if you
felt like that every single day
your life would be dramatically
different also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number three match your action to
your mission the number one biggest
thing that you are missing is momentum
you're a genius you've got Michael
Jordan level Talent you are the best in
the world at something but until you
match your effort to your capabilities
your dreams will never ever happen so
yesterday I had a young preacher reach
out to me on Instagram young like early
teenager reach out to me on Instagram
and say hey Evan I'm a preacher I'm
trying to get my career going I want to
make YouTube videos I want to spread a
message can you watch my video and give
me some feedback
and I love first off I love young
entrepreneurs who are going after it who
are not just sitting there making
excuses as to why they can't because
they don't come from the family they
don't have the right education you know
the right gear to make a video there's
this guy just takes out his phone
against a simple background poor
lighting doesn't matter right just takes
out his phone starts recording the video
and he's pretty good
right for for a kid who's 14 15 16 years
old he's pretty good he's way better
than I was he's way better than I was
when I started making videos at I don't
know when I started making videos 10
years ago how old am I now 39 29. he's
better at 14 15 16 than I was at 29.
that's amazing I love it but here's the
thing he was only making a video once a
week
and so he said I love it man but you
gotta you gotta match your actions to
your missions you got to keep going if
you want to be the greatest preacher on
the planet you got to make more content
one to practice right if you're a file
lead if you're an expert if what you are
creating comes from here and you just
speak it out you need to be making a
video every day every day if you can
freestyle as an artist as a rapper you
should be making a video every single
day now if your videos require some
massive setup not because it's about the
quality of your thought but it's about
fancy stunts or something that requires
a lot more fine but if it's thought
leadership if it's content that's just
coming out of your head
right the quality of your ideas every
single day
once you get better the more you do it
the better you're gonna get took me 350
videos until I wasn't completely
embarrassed by my own content right I
couldn't watch it back because I was I
was too embarrassed but
now as I watch my videos it's fine
whatever Nina comes in and she's seeing
me watch my videos I always have this
big grin on my face like I'm I'm
cheering myself on I'm like yeah yeah
it's really good and and there's
definitely still tons of room to improve
but it took me 350 videos before I
wasn't completely embarrassed so now I'm
6000 or something videos in it's hard to
keep track
your actions have to map your Ambitions
so if that's you if you've got ideas
you've got knowledge stop coming up with
excuses and make the content film it and
post today and again tomorrow and again
the next day and again the next day and
when you're creating so much content one
again you're getting better because the
the quantity leads to the quality but
two you get less attached to one video
having to be the thing
so often you make one piece of content
one painting one song One video you make
it and then that has to be the thing
you're getting feedback and you're
destroyed if it doesn't take off if this
video doesn't take off great next
right next next next keep going keep
creating you need momentum
so your actions have to map to your
Ambitions right whatever idea you have
in your head you want to be the next
Oprah of whatever industry great
let's see it let's see it in the work
let's see do any energy let's see it in
the output that you are creating every
single day now I have a three-step
process that I think will help let's
Dive In Step number one is make sure
your actions map to your Ambitions so
look at your calendar open up your
calendars see what you're doing for the
next week what are you doing for the
next week right success is habits so you
have these big Ambitions you have these
lofty goals these dreams amazing I want
you to accomplish them show me in your
calendar where you are spending time to
actually make that happen because a
dream alone is not enough it can be
super exciting as an entrepreneur to
dream to sit there like oh man I'm going
to create this and we get lost in our
head of all the amazing things you can
do nothing counts until you actually get
out and start executing
I've had people who work into my
workshops when I was on tour earlier
this year who've been sitting on a dream
for a decade Plus
and they're still tinkerings still
playing with it and it's exciting while
it's still in your head it doesn't count
until you get out and start executing
and so I want to have 10 million
subscribers on YouTube as my next goal
awesome what am I doing I'm making
videos every week multiple times for for
I don't know how many channels anymore
right thousands of videos
we've made videos every single day for
at least five or six years at least
usually multiple videos but I don't we
haven't missed a day in at least five or
six years and that's where the growth
comes from and it's not that I'm super
human right you could do the exact same
thing just make sure your actions map to
your Ambitions you say you want this
then you have to block it off in your
calendar and you have to make sure that
you are spending time pursuing your
goals every single week step number two
is get a 254. so I have a 254 series
it's a free video series we'll link it
Up Down Below I've already called it out
actually earlier on in this video
where every day for 254 days I send you
an unlisted video by email
private just for you on a certain topic
so it could be on self-love could be
unconfidence could be a motivation could
be for writers could be for women could
be on my black Excellence series there's
lots of different 254s the idea here is
it takes up to 254 days of consecutive
action to build a habit so if you want
to change a habit you want to change
your mindset you want to change your
your way of thinking you want to be more
motivated
most people don't give it enough time it
takes as long as 254 days of consecutive
action to build a habit the average is
66 days the the best case scenario is 18
days of consecutive action so if you're
trying something for two weeks it's not
enough time even in the best case
scenario it's not enough time to build a
habit and so whatever it is that you
want to build surround yourself with it
for 254 days create your own 254 Series
so if that's listening to Dan Pena great
if that's watching my video is great if
that's listening to a podcast a
different YouTube channel reading the
book great like whoever embodies the
thing that you want to own that you want
to be a part of that you want to jump in
levels to you're here you want to jump
here who's playing here and doing it
consistently and then inject that inject
a piece of them into your morning
routine every day and they will pull you
up even if you never meet Dan Pena even
if you never meet me if you are
consuming the content every day we will
pull you up we will pull you up to the
next level it's impossible it's not
possible to watch a video from me or
watch a video from Dan Pena or watch
your video from whoever it is that you
aspire to be like it's impossible to
watch for 254 days and pay attention not
while you're doing the dishes or
something else pay attention and not be
pulled to another level
promise people aren't consistent enough
so create your own 254 and set number
three is sleep this is kind of a weird
one but I felt like I had to say it for
this video a lot of people default the
saying I need to wake up an hour early I
need to I need to wake up at 5am I need
to go to sleep and just wake up earlier
and and that can definitely work it
could be a productivity hack but I think
before worrying about giving up on sleep
there are a lot of people who don't get
enough sleep and as a result you're not
productive before giving up on sleep I
would say make sure that the 16 hours
that you are awake are actually
meaningful right if you're gonna sleep
for eight hours right most of you
probably aren't even there but let's see
you're gonna sleep for eight hours great
that gives you 16 hours to be productive
during the day if you're messing around
for the 16 hours going to 17 hours will
not make you more productive you're just
gonna have less sleep be more sleep
deprived and not to get the work done
you need to so before giving up on sleep
I would highly recommend that you audit
your schedule and ask yourself what am I
doing during the 16 hours that I am
awake and how can I maximize that time
to actually be productive and move my
goals forward and if you still get down
to no my 16 hours are fully optimized
and I need to cut into my sleep and that
makes sense for you awesome go do it but
I wouldn't do that as your first default
step which is a big mistake I think a
lot of entrepreneurs make rule number
four ignore what others think if you
live your life based off the opinions of
other people you will never do anything
great take a look at who you're worried
about people who are not with their life
people who never went and took their
shot people who spend their life
complaining instead of trying to change
something is that who you want to be so
worried about what they think about your
decisions if anything you want to do the
exact opposite of what they're telling
you to do you don't want their life so
stop living your life by their rules so
I had an amazing one-on-one with an
entrepreneur yesterday at my q a session
here in Toronto that I do weekly and I
feel for her she's such a talented
amazing gifted entrepreneur and we
talked about your purpose coming from
your pain and she went through some
massive pain that guided her to the
success right now and on her path to
personal development but she's afraid to
share what happened
and she said maybe in a year or two like
give me a year to work on it maybe I'll
share it because she's afraid of what
people will think she's afraid that if
it doesn't work out that she may not be
able to get another job she's afraid of
all these things that people might say
about her if they found out the truth
problem is that's your path
I don't care about what where you're at
right now I need to know where you've
come from I need to know that you look
like me I need to know that your story
is like mine and so by living in the
shadows and being afraid to tell the
truth what you're doing is one not
letting people connect to you as a real
person right this fake perfect version
of you isn't something that people can
connect to two you make it so that
whatever you went through it you're
telling yourself that it's it's shameful
and you're telling other people that
it's shameful too but if you come out
and talk about what happened then the
people who feel ashamed about it they
now can come out and say huh I'm not the
only one
this happens to other people too I'm a
little bit more normal and three if you
want to build a business if you want to
create a YouTube channel if you want to
have a podcast you want to be an author
you want to write a book that's the
thing that's gonna actually help take
you off
that's the thing there was a a great
video that I told her about about a
woman who gained 70 pounds uh from
having a child so she's pregnant she
gained 70 pounds
and she had a 10 pound baby and now she
had 60 pounds of extra
fat on her right 60 pounds so that's a
lot and so she's trying to lose it and
she's working out and she's eaten
healthy and she finally gets down to
having a six-pack apps and looking great
and then somebody noticed that when she
bent over
that that they could see the flaps of
skin when she stood up it was all six
pack but when she bent over there was
flaps of skin and what most people would
have done is deleted that video pretend
like it didn't exist not talk about that
comments right only show the perfect
version look how much weight I lost but
she did something different and said she
said yeah
that's my body now that's what happens
when you gain 70 pounds in pregnancy and
pump out a 10 pound baby
and that became a rallying cry that one
moment of vulnerability of saying hey
I'm still not perfect like look look at
this saggy skin that I still have
that's what brought people to her now
she's not just another mom who lost
weight and did this workout plan and
meal plan right that that connection was
real and now she's built a Million
Dollar Plus business from selling
e-courses and her recipes and everything
else that she goes through that's the
thing
this is your competitive Advantage your
purpose your pain your story is your
competitive Advantage I do not want to
learn from you until I know that you've
been through what I'm going through
I can't relate to that story right I
can't tell that story I can't tell a mom
who gained 70 pounds how to lose weight
that's not my story I can't relate to it
but helping entrepreneurs I can because
I struggled and I suffered and I was
making 300 a month and I was eating the
same bean salad lunch every day and I
celebrated with only McDonald's french
fries because I couldn't afford to buy
it all of it I struggle with with fear
and embarrassment and and shame all of
it I know what it's like I've been
through that and why I do what I do now
is because I want to try to make the
path a little bit easier for the next
generation of entrepreneurs for you I
want you to feel like you're not alone I
want you to feel like there's a place
you can come to with a beautiful
community of believe Nation where we're
supporting each other and this content
every single day across multiple
channels that you can go and digest and
dive into and hopefully hopefully
hopefully make your path just a little
bit easier because I wish I had this
when I was getting started when I was a
19 year old entrepreneur who was
insecure and and ashamed and embarrassed
and not willing to talk to anybody about
the problems I was going through right
that's the thing that will connect
people to you but if you're so afraid of
what people's judgments are going to be
you're never going to get started I
believe humans are built to serve you're
built to serve you want to help other
people it's hardwired into US studies
show that the impact of serving other
people has the same effect on your brain
as food and sex it's hardwired into you
you want to help other people and at the
same time you're afraid of judgment so
how do you help other people if you're
also afraid of judgment it's it's having
your foot on the gas going to break at
the same time you know you're capable of
more but then you just standing on the
same spot it's the worst and so you have
to let go of the opinions of other
people some people may not like what
you're doing that's okay that can't
prevent you from service that can't
prevent you from fulfilling your mission
that can't prevent you from living the
life you want because you're going to be
95 years old looking back on your life
and regretting it knowing you're capable
of more but never taking action so how
do you better deal with criticism I'm
going to give you a three-step process
step number one is have empathy have
empathy
if you believe like I believe that
humans are built to serve right we're
built to serve then if somebody is being
critical and negative when they are
built to serve how bad does their life
have to be that is forcing them to act
this way how bad does somebody's life
have to be to come to your YouTube video
and leave a nasty comment or to tell you
to your face that you suck and your idea
is never going to work how bad does
their life have to be so have some
empathy like their life sucks
and they're lashing out at not just you
everybody around them so have empathy
when you have empathy removes the sting
out of the words right now it doesn't
touch you as much because if anything
you feel sorry for that person you don't
have to say hey I feel so sorry for you
you don't need to go make it worse or
have it go on an ego trip but just know
inside have empathy feel sorry for them
and not let it hit you as hard when
they're giving you some criticism about
your idea or you number two is look for
a gem a lot of times in the criticism
there's actually something you can learn
from a lot of times when somebody
criticizes their idea or lose a nasty
comment on YouTube
you might just write it off of that
person's being a hater
Jam in there
that when somebody sugarcoats it and
packages it nicely and say I love you I
love your chain I love everything you're
doing I love all your ideas but this one
little tiny tiny thing that I think if
you fix would really help if if that's
the only way you can take feedback
you're going to lose
you're going to get nasty comments and
some of them are just pure haters and
it's their own problem but sometimes
buried within that nasty comment is
actually a kernel of truth there's a gem
in there for you and so if you can
remove the sting right have empathy
remove the sting then look at the comma
and see is there anything from this
comment is there anything in this
critique that I can actually learn to
make my idea or my concept better look
for the gem and then number three is
addressed to those who are dealing with
their parents who might be your biggest
critic understand that your parents are
pilgrims your parents are pilgrims your
parents come from a different era if
you're 20 years old right now as an
example the opportunity is available to
you using this
are things that your parents at 20 years
old can understand the opportunities
available to you right now are insane
compared to what your parents had when
they're at your same age and so when
they're saying go get a safe job go be a
doctor go be a lawyer go be accountant
go be go do something you can work at
some job forever that's actually their
version of love for you right that's
empathy empathy step into their shoes
they love you chances are your parents
love you I hope but chances are they do
and so they're trying to give you advice
that they would have given themselves X
number of years ago back when they were
your age
they just don't understand what's
available right now a lot of times a lot
of people who are critiquing you
criticizing you it may be out of love
they just don't understand the path that
you see they don't understand the world
that we're living in right now they
don't understand everything that can be
created
and so have that empathy for them
understand that that's where they're
coming from they love you and again
removes the sting out of the words and
then you can see how do you want to act
how do you want to react to these people
around you that would make you feel
proud whatever that is in your head then
go and do it rule number five the last
one before our very special bonus clip
study successful people the fastest way
to achieve your goals is to model the
people who've already achieved the same
goals that you have a lot of success
success excludes the famous expression
and it's true people have already
figured out the thing that you are
struggling to figure out and the more
you are stuck trying to come up with
every idea yourself the harder you're
making it on yourself and this is man
this is one of the two fundamental
lessons that I have learned in my life
my life that is saved my life and my
business my first company I learned this
lesson first when I was 20 years old out
of desperation where I was making no
money and struggling and I quit on my
business partner I quit you know like I
can't keep going I quit
and I modeled Bill Gates I just asked
myself who has done this before model
Bill Gates put it to work had some
success I've told the story many times
but it's important because that was the
thing that saved me that's that's what
saved my company you know in modeling
Bill Gates and how we started Microsoft
that's what saved my business and
allowed me to keep going and I'm I'm now
here you know if I didn't do that I'd
probably have some job that I'm not
happy with
20 years later still stuck in the same
job that I'm not happy with and that
idea
came to me at a moment of desperation
it's not even the smartest idea right I
mean I wasn't into personal development
I wasn't reading books I didn't I didn't
know anything and I wish I had somebody
guide me or Mentor me and it's a very
basic idea model success you know I wish
I'd watch videos like this I wish they
were available when I was 19 20 years
old it really just came out of moment of
desperation where I'm at my parents home
crying my face off because I just quit
on this business that I cared about and
I
I didn't want to fail but I felt there
was no option I just felt overwhelmed
frustrated it just was not working out
and
in
everything felt lost
and it was only in that absolute moment
of Crisis that I thought maybe somebody
else has done this before where up until
that point I felt like I had to come up
with every idea myself like oh maybe we
should do this maybe we should do that
maybe we could try this and nothing
would seem to be working and it wasn't
until I asked that question and then I
found Bill Gates and how he started
Microsoft and that's what started
turning the company around whatever
problem you're facing right now it's
been addressed many many many many times
by many many many many many many
successful people
your job becomes to find out who they
are and to go back and study how they
how they solve that problem and it's
really important to figure out how they
solve the exact problem that you're
struggling with right now so what I told
myself when I was looking at Bill Gates
was
I don't care how Bill Gates makes an
extra million dollars right now how did
he get started how do you go from zero
to one what was the thing that that
built this company up and for all these
people the bigger they are the easier it
is to research their story
Bill Gates only came to mind because I
had a software company and I just said
who's built a software company it was
not
even that structured or thought out or
in-depth or or you know in detail he was
the first guy that I thought of that had
a software company Bill Gates Microsoft
how do you do it that was it
and in looking at a story I found out
that Microsoft built their business
through Partnerships
and their big deal came when they made a
partnership with IBM and IBM at the time
was the biggest computer manufacturer on
the planet so the deal was every IBM
that was shipped every computer that was
shipped from the biggest computer
manufacturer in the world had Microsoft
software on it it was a huge deal that
blew up the company and that was pretty
easy to find right the transitional
moment in the company
it's like wow okay Partnerships that's
interesting I I maybe can do that but
Microsoft was already a seven million
dollar company when they made that deal
now 7 million was nothing compared to
what they would go on to be right
billions and billions of dollars but
it was seven million dollars it was
still more than what I had
right seven million dollars felt like a
giant company compared to me making 300
bucks a month right so
the next layer is to dig a Little Deeper
not just their big break which is
important but how did they get started
like how did they get to The Big Break
is really valuable it's really helpful
to figure out and again the bigger the
person is that you're modeling the
easier it is to find the content you
just might have to dig you might have to
go read biographies read articles read
interviews watch videos to figure out
those early Parts not their just their
upbringing but what were the things that
they did that led to the big
breakthrough not just what the big
breakthrough was big breakthrough is
super important but the steps that led
to the brick big breakthrough even more
important if you're at the beginning
getting started so Microsoft big
breakthrough was the IBM deal they're
already seven million dollar company how
do they get to become a seven million
dollar company that was the million
dollar question maybe the seven million
dollar question and it was still through
Partnerships
so what Microsoft did was they had
software and they looked at any hardware
that existed
that needed software for it
and they would go in and Pitch their
software their first deal was with the
mitz Altair and
the mid-tal tear was a was a piece of
hardware and it was featured on the on
the cover of uh of their magazine that
was the big magazine for the computer
industry at the time and they needed
software and Bill Gates and uh called
them up with his partner Paul Allen and
said hey we've got software for the
mid-saltier that you can use that will
make it a lot more valuable valuable to
people and they didn't even have it
built yet
on the on the on the plane ride over to
go meet the company Bill Gates was
finishing up the code to go
program and they hope that it would work
and luckily it did when they when they
had the meeting uh so I don't I don't
necessarily like that part of lying that
you've got something but it's
interesting to know how he did it the
the boldness the the willingness to
reach out and say hey I've got something
that can help you we're things that I
really struggled with as a 19 year old
entrepreneur believing that what I had
was great and I could really solve big
problems where Bill Gates was saying
yeah we got this even though he didn't
have it yet and he wrote it on the plane
on the on the way over right but it was
still through Partnerships
and anytime Microsoft was entering
something new they found Partnerships
and so I applied that strategy to me and
I started looking for who can who can we
partner with not like a business partner
where they own a piece of our company
but who can we partner with that it's a
distribution deal
and the first uh company that I
made a deal with was out of the UK and
we had a arrangement for them to
represent us in the UK and a couple of
the markets in Europe where they would
be Distributing our product and we made
an exclusive deal so that anytime we got
a lead from those markets it would go to
them and they would be doing their own
marketing promotion as well and in
exchange for that exclusive partnership
they would pay us thirteen and a half
thousand dollars up front
and I remember I was I was so scared to
ask for that it felt like a giant number
what if they said no this big potential
deal and uh and they said yes they said
yes and we had we had money in our bank
account
for the first time which was wild and
crazy and
that was a fantastic deal for us and
more important is it it said it gave us
hope which is maybe important to give us
momentum which is Mega important and it
gave us a model to keep following and so
what I what I ended up doing afterwards
was let's go get more partnership deals
let's go get more partnership deals and
the people who ended up buying us was
basically a partnership deal so instead
of partnering with our company they just
bought the whole business
and that's how we exited all because of
modeling Bill Gates when I quit on my
company so whatever
problem you're facing personal or
business people have solved it humans
have been around for a long time
somebody has solved this problem you do
not have to be a genius and come up with
every new idea yourself can your
creativity and love and Panache help yes
of course
but you don't have to have the seed for
every great idea
and chances are
the problem that you're facing right now
there's an answer
10 minutes away from you from a YouTube
video that's that's online from a book
from a podcast from an interview there's
an answer out there for you and if you
just default to saying I'm going to
model success I'm going to find the
people who've done this and exactly how
they solve that specific problem that
you're facing right now not how they're
living their life right now but how did
they get over the hurdle that you're
facing when you can dig deep and find
those answers and again the bigger the
person is
the more accessible the content is
if you want to learn about Bill Gates's
early life or Steve Jobs's early life or
Oprah Winfrey's early life or whoever it
is it's accessible it's there you can
find this stuff
and it gives you the hope
that it's possible for you and it gives
you the specific strategies that you can
use to apply to your life right now so
you can start seeing results
success leaves Clues
whatever problem you've got
gold model success
most people aren't happy in life because
they're living somebody else's truth
you're not living your truth you're
living somebody else's version of it
your parents your family your culture
your Society you're living somebody
else's version of it and so you're never
happy because you never explored it you
never picked at it you never found out
what you could be and you settled for
something less than what you're capable
of you know you're capable of more you
may not know what the thing is that you
should be doing but you know it's not
this thing right in front of you I can't
tell you how many people I've met on
this tour who have that story to share I
had a woman whose father told her that
women should not be doing any kind of
entrepreneurial Ventures that women are
meant to be teachers and so she spent 15
years being a teacher before Having the
courage to jump off and start her own
business and now she has a multi-million
dollar construction business I had a
girl come up in Albuquerque where I am
right now who studied for years to be an
accountant why because her mom was an
accountant so her mom made her go study
to become an accountant and she didn't
know what she wanted to do so she said
okay great yeah I'll be an accountant
she just graduated and realized I don't
want to be an accountant this isn't for
me it's easy it's the path that my
parents took like it's great for me to
get into it I can get easy money you
know my mom said I'll like it when the
money starts coming in but money's
coming in and I don't like it I want to
do something else I know I'm meant for
something greater and so she told her
mom I don't want to do this I want to
learn how to be a Management Consultant
am I going to go back to school that
takes a lot of guts that takes a lot of
Courage most people do not have that
courage most people
's courage to send up to their parents
and say I don't want this life it
doesn't mean you have to hate them you
have to attack them you have to tell
them they're wrong this is for you you
don't want that life most people never
have that courage and the story that
comes to mind for me is accio Morita and
use this as motivation as wisdom if you
are trying to battle your parents or
your culture your friends or your
Society remember accio Morita he started
Sony now he came from 11 or 12
generations of sake Brewers Japanese
background the Japanese culture is super
family oriented and the oldest always
takes over the family business the
oldest has to follow in line with what
the family was doing and so he was
expected to take over the sake business
and it's not just one generation you're
talking 11 or 12 Generations in a
Japanese society and he said I don't
want to do this
I want to start my own business a
technology company at a time when Japan
was known for super low quality products
this is a man who put Japan on the map
for high quality products that products
coming out of Japan meant something was
a stamp of quality because of accio
Morita and he went on to build one of
the most successful brains in the world
Sony but it starts with Having the
courage Having the courage to say that's
not my life that's not my truth that's
your truth and it's how to love your
parents love you your friends love you
your Society your community they love
you it's not that I hate it's very few
parents who say do this because you're
going to suffer you know it's out of
love they just have a different version
of it their world is different they
don't understand the world that you're
growing up in
and so you have to have the crew to go
off and start your truth the challenging
part though is it's uncertain you don't
know what it looks like you haven't
started
and so here's what I call the two
percent difference this
is the secret to moving forward as soon
as you get an idea as soon as you get an
idea you get an idea for something trust
that idea trusted idea that it's
actually the right thing for you because
what we typically do is you get an idea
and then your brain talks you down from
doing it your brain says well you're not
talented enough you haven't gone to
school you don't have the money you know
the resources it talks you down from
doing that big crazy thing
I believe that idea came to you for a
reason and you need to trust it and go
take action on it even though it doesn't
make sense you're trying to solve a
matter of the heart with your head you
can't logically think your way through
how you're going to feel about something
you can't you can't think your way
through if you're gonna like sushi or
not you can't think your way through if
you're gonna love somebody or not you
can't
similarly in Finding Your Truth finding
your passion finding your calling you
cannot think your way through it you
have to feel it and so the starting
point is going off and doing it and as
soon as you get that idea while you're
feeling bold while you're feeling
inspired to go off and take some kind of
action I call it the two percent
difference don't worry about trying to
get to 100 don't worry about planning
and strategizing and figuring it out and
thinking that's what most of us do you
get an idea you think you start thinking
right you plan how do I get to that
hundred percent no you've lost because
you're gonna wake up tomorrow a
different person because you're gonna go
home today plan plan plan and wake up
tomorrow a different person and then not
take action because you're scared
because your brain will start talking
you down from that crazy big idea your
brain will talk you down from going off
and living your truth that's what's
gonna happen that's what always happens
and so while you're feeling the energy
and the momentum you got to take some
action instead of planning how to get to
100 of the way you take action
immediately on getting two percent of
the way two percent the two percent
difference go from zero to two percent
if you can't take immediate momentum to
getting two percent of the way you will
never get to 100 you have an idea to
make a YouTube channel great go make a
video right now today ASAP the two
percent difference make your first video
right now with your cell phone
what most people will do is start
researching right what am I going to
talk about what am I going to wear
what's my hair gonna look like how what
camera do I need to get what what phone
do I need to get right what's my
lighting gonna be what microphone think
think think
s you're gonna perfect your way of ever
living your truth
the beginning is messy it's supposed to
be messy go off and get your two percent
difference towards finding and living
your truth quick example my story I'm
here in Albuquerque New Mexico right now
I was walking down a beautiful summer
day last year and I decided that I was
going to take Nina to every city in
North America with a million plus people
every city in North America 1 million
plus people that was my decision great
what's my first step action the two
percent difference so it's not here's
what most people do it's not go home and
research how many cities there are it's
not go home and make a plan for how
we're gonna do this there's lots of
reasons why it's not gonna work I need
to have a full-time job I had no idea
how many cities there were I had no idea
what the next step was going to be just
do something immediate action and so I
thought right away five seconds later
here's my goal grade five seconds later
this weekend let's hit one city
Boston Nina never been to Boston so I
thought Boston was the closest city to
Toronto it wasn't Pittsburgh actually
was and on my tour the people in
Pittsburgh told me they let me know that
Pittsburgh is closer
but it doesn't matter this weekend we're
gonna go to Boston it was a Wednesday
that I decided and on Friday night we
were leaving for Boston boom I hit two
percent just 50 cities we're gonna hit
one this weekend we're gonna get two
percent of the way done on the way back
from Boston we decided to do this tour
that I'm on right now and now we're
gonna hit 50 of the cities on my list
momentum that's the thing that's missing
momentum because you're trying to be
perfect you're trying to fully
understand your truth but you can't
think your way through your truth you
have to experience it and feel it and
the starting point is a two percent
difference so take whatever idea that
you have and train yourself I want to
burn this into your nervous system this
is one of the most important things you
can do of all time as soon as you get an
idea action idea action idea action the
more you can shortcut that that window
instead of taking a week to take action
or a day to take action immediate five
seconds idea boom some kind of two
percent action and expect it not to be
perfect expected not to be the best plan
my plan was wrong right Pittsburgh was
closer in my head I thought it was
Boston we went down the wrong path but
the momentum is what matters and now
we're 50 of the way and now I'm going to
close that Gap and get the rest of it
the two percent difference go find your
truth
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to turn your passion into a
successful business check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there to build a happy little bit
Consulting business you do it that's the
path is already there it's easy to let
people have done it a lot of people
actually at half a million it's enough
it's like a lot of people their ambition
actually really slows down when they hit
that half a million half a million